[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
abend knapp
59.000 neuinfektionen meldet das lka
heute und deutlich steigende inzidenz
das bundesgesundheitsministerium geht
davon aus dass nikon schon in wenigen
tagen auch in deutschland die
vorherrschende corona variante sein wird
wie rasant es dann nach oben geht kann
man ja in anderen ländern sehen die
59.000 infektionen von heute werden uns
wohl schon sehr bald wenig vorkommen
damit wird dann auch die frage drängend
wie sich ein zu großer auswahl von
personal verhindern lässt an der stelle
immerhin hat nikon auch vorteile sagt
der bundesgesundheitsminister mit dem
ich vorhin dazu ein gespräch geführt
habe zuvor berichtet sabine kommen
worauf er und die gesundheitsminister
ministerin der länder sich heute
geeinigt haben ihr bericht beginnt in
bremen wo omikron sich bereits massiv
ausbreitet
jeden tag am pc recherchieren auch an
den feiertagen noch nie waren im bremer
gesundheitsamt so viele mitarbeiterinnen
und helfer im einsatz wie jetzt ihre
aufgabe positiv getestete anrufen und so
enge kontaktpersonen ermitteln die
bundeswehr unterstützt jetzt das team
nicht genug angesichts der rasanten
verbreitung der omicron variante der
neue chef des bremer gesundheitsamts
wünscht sich deutlich mehr
digitalisierung
es gibt zu viel manuelle arbeiten und
die müssen automatisiert werden es muss
keiner kein mensch muss mehr angucken ob
eine meldung doppel eingegangen ist das
kann ich automatisieren und da kann ich
unheimlich geschwindigkeit gewinnen bei
der video konferenz der
gesundheitsminister bringen fordert die
vorsitzende weitere schritte ich glaube
wie man sagt sind wir uns sehr einig
darüber dass wir
eine verkürzung machen müssen der
quarantäne zeiten aber es muss
verantwortlich sein und die
gesundheitsminister haben
mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister auch darüber
geredet dass muss auch alles praktikabel
umsetzbar sein die
gesundheitsministerinnen der länder
schlagen vor dass bereits nach fünf
tagen geimpfte mitarbeiterinnen im
gesundheitswesen bei der polizei und
anderen kritischen bereichen bei
negativem pcr-test ihre isolation
beenden dürfen eine ungeimpfte
kontaktpersonen können nach sieben tagen
durch eine negative pcr-test ihre
quarantäne beenden für gebuchte
kontaktpersonen entfällt die quarantäne
selbsttests viren aber empfohlen wir
sind alle groß groß herausgefordert und
ich meine gerade die
gesundheitsministerin runde hat ja eine
hohe verantwortung ist im grunde
genommen seit 22 monate an der front sag
ich mal um das auch letztendlich
umzusetzen und diesbezüglich kann ich
sagen sind wir da zu einem guten
ergebnis gekommen bremen war bisher
spitzenreiter beim impfen und wurde
dafür bundesweit gewürdigt doch jetzt
verzeichnet die stadt rekord inzidenz
für den wissenschaftler hjf ist das kein
widerspruch wenn man sehr früh und
effektiv gedämpft viele menschen
erreicht das ist jetzt aber eben für
viele schon fünf oder sechs monate her
und damit ist jetzt leider der
impfschutz gegen omikron der
infektionsschutz ist nicht mehr
vorhanden das heißt jetzt also dringend
möglichst schnell alle postern und da
muss bremen und ganz bundesrepublik halt
möglichst zügig vorankommen bis das
boostern allerdings greift haben die
medizinischen labore viel zu tun gerade
in bremen trotz hoher im quote 1
spitzenreiter der pandemie
darüber wollen wir mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister sprechen guten
abend ellerbach frühen abend vor slomka
wenn man sich jetzt diese neuen
quarantäne und isolierung regeln ansieht
wie viel risiko steckt in diesem
pragmatismus der dahinter steckt ich
glaube wir minimieren das risiko sondern
wir gehen in die richtung dass man eine
sehr sichere lösung hat gleichzeitig
aber auch die bereiche der kritischen
infrastruktur lebensfähig hält das wird
erreicht indem man eben die quarantäne
dauer und auch die isolations dauer
verkürzt aber immer sicher stellt dass
durch einen pcr-test
gewährleistet dass niemand ist noch
ansteckend wenn man nach frankreich
sieht der wird für bestimmte das
medizinisches fachpersonal das infiziert
ist die dürfen inzwischen auch oder
müssen weiter arbeiten selbst wenn die
pcr test noch positiv sind so was hat
man sich aber es vor kurzem hat nicht
vorstellen können kann das bei uns auch
noch so weit kommen ich glaube dass wir
das in deutschland abwenden können wir
können bis zu 2,3 millionen pcr tests
pro woche machen das ist eine enorme
kapazität und wendet diese pcr-test
einsätzen für diejenigen die sie
besonders brauchen also diejenigen die
also in der kritischen infrastruktur
sind in krankenhäusern arbeiten oder
besonders gefährdet sind dann kommen wir
mit den test hin und brauchen nicht ins
risiko zu gehen aber ich meinte ich
glaube da wir uns missverstanden ich
meinte die arbeiten trotz positiven pcr
test also legt sich eine mangel vom test
und es liegt ein mangel von personal ja
das werden wir hier nicht machen also
wir werden mit der freiheit testung
arbeiten also wenn man tatsächlich mit
positiven test in die arbeit zurück geht
dann ist das ein großes risiko und das
werden wir hier nicht dass wir das dass
das werden wir nicht wollen jedenfalls
nicht wollen am freitag kommt ja dann
noch mal die berühmte mpk den begriff
kennen wir ja inzwischen alle in dieser
pandemie werden sie weitere kontakt
beschränkungen fordern also zum beispiel
über die zehn personen für geimpfte mit
denen man sich privat treffen darf
hinaus also ich glaube dass wir jetzt
vor der großen omikron welle die wir ja
versuchen abzuwenden oder abzuschwächen
dass wir da noch mal über kontakt
begrenzungen sprechen müssen ich hätte
das für notwendig und wir müssen mit
augenmaß vorgehen aber unsere maßnahmen
wirken auch das muss man sagen aber wir
werden wahrscheinlich noch einmal
zulegen müssen aber konkret wollen sie
da jetzt noch nicht werden ich möchte da
wirklich niemandem vorgreifen so das
muss ja gut vorbereitet sein und muss
nachher in also einvernehmen von allen
geschlossen werden dennoch also wir sind
andere situation wo wir an die
quarantäne regel daran müssen wir müssen
etwas mehr sicherheit noch bieten wir
müssen die booster impfung kampagne
fortführen ostern ist das
allerwichtigste was eigentlich der beste
schutz vor der omicron variante und hier
appelliere ich auch noch mal an sie
ärztinnen und ärzte da noch mal
nachzulegen was wir das hohe tempo der
poster kampagne welches wir vor
weihnachten gehabt haben dass wir das
wieder aufnehmen am hellbach einen ort
wo immer noch sehr viele ungeimpfte
zusammentreffen sind die schulen die
gleichzeitig sehr hohe
überdurchschnittliche instanzen haben
die sehr besorgt sie das das besorgt
mich sehr allerdings weiß man auch dass
also bei der omicron variante das wird
ja die dominierende wenn nicht die
alleinige reihe und den wenigen wochen
sein was dort masken sehr gut wirken von
daher appelliere ich wirklich an alle
länder dass man hier vorgibt dass in den
schulen masken getragen werden weil
tatsächlich ist die maske bei der
omicron variante sehr effizient und
würde gerade in den schulen eine große
sicherheit bieten sie waren ja früher
also auch noch vor ihrer zeit als
minister hätte da vielleicht auch noch
offen äußern konnten sehr sehr kritisch
gegenüber so einen leichten haltung wenn
kinder sich mit corona infizieren sie
sagten sie gehen davon aus dass fünf
prozent auch kinder longo fit bekommen
können und das ohne durchseuchung auch
überhaupt keinen fall stattfinden sollte
das sein menschenexperiment mit
unabsehbaren langzeitfolgen dann müsst
ihr dieses kategorische ausschließen von
schulschließungen sie doch eigentlich
unruhigen also ich lese sowieso
kategorisch nichts aus und ich bleibe
dabei eine durchseuchung mit der omicron
variante wäre für die kinder wie aber
auch für die erwachsenen in keiner weise
verantwortbar es wird ja immer
vorgetragen oder oft vorgetragene micon
verlaufe leichter als die data war das
stimmt aber es ist trotzdem keine
leichte erkrankung und es wird bei
vielen auch bleibende schäden
hinterlassen
das kann man nicht also auf die leichte
schulter nehmen hier werden viele schwer
krank werden und werden auch
längerfristig krank werden und das
wollen wir gerade unseren kindern auf
jeden fall ersparen daher wird nichts
ausgeschlossen da sagen manche eltern
dann hätte ich es gerne wenn man kind
nicht nur durch stoßlüften geschützt
wurde in der schule
naja stoßlüften ist natürlich eine
maßnahme die man also machen muss das
ist gar keine frage aber ich kann nur
noch mal wiederholen also die motten die
maske werden die maske während des
unterrichts getragen wird das bringt
hier eine menge das bringt bei omikron
wahrscheinlich mehr als bei der delta
variante und sie würden ihren kindern
ffp zwei masken geben oder genügend auch
die dünneren und angenehmer zu tragen op
masken
die besser die maske ist desto besser
wird sie natürlich daher also
würde ich meinen eigenen kindern
tatsächlich des sp2 maske empfehlen das
ist klar und
nichtsdestotrotz darf man aber nicht
sagen also dass eine andere maske nicht
weg sondern auch andere masken wirken
wenn die kinder fsb zwei masken tragen
können und kommen daher mit der atemluft
gut klar also habe ich das gefühl zu
wenig luft zu ziehen ungefährlich ist
sie für kinder auf jeden fall dann ist
der vfb zwei masken natürlich besser
leider ist es so dass es für viele
kinder keine passenden ssb zwei masken
gibt es nur für die größeren kinder wo
man typischerweise solche masken findet
das ist etwas woran man noch arbeiten
könnte herr lauterbach vielen dank für
das gespräch ich danke ihnen
der hitze lange demonstrieren will muss
dafür ja keine genehmigung erbitten aber
eine versammlung unter freiem himmel
muss angemeldet werden und sie können
gegebenenfalls mit auflagen versehen
werden in pandemie zeiten zum beispiel
mit abstandsregeln oder begrenzter
personenzahl mit den sogenannten
spaziergängen wird versucht diesen teil
des versammlungsrechts zu umgehen auf
antrag der afg wurde im sächsischen
landtag heute darüber debattiert ob die
für sachsen geltenden auflagen
aufgehoben werden soll jenseits dieser
parteipolitischen und auch juristischen
diskussionen formiert sich inzwischen
eine gegenbewegung zu den crooner
protestlern in bautzen etwa will eine
bürgerinitiative nicht länger still
hinnehmen dass die stadt ständig zur
bühne lautstark minderheiten wird
kommissions bericht
sie wollen ihre stadt nicht den hetzern
überlassen heinrich schleppers christian
thiede aus bautzen haben deshalb eine
online-petition gestartet mit inzwischen
fast 50.000 unterstützern die
zivilgesellschaft will endlich
sichtbarer werden regelkonform deshalb
heute ein gespräch mit der örtlichen
polizei
oder müssen demonstrieren und parolen
brüllen die im endeffekt an verhohlen
original von 1981
und ich wollte sondern auch die selber
mit dabei da haben wir polizisten in die
hand gedrückt heute kriegen die
polizisten eine faust ins gesicht zu
bekommen
in bautzen zeigen von woche zu woche
mehr menschen ihren unmut gegen die
korona maßnahmen oft aggressiv und
gewalttätig in sachsen dürfen sich laut
aktueller corona schutzverordnung nur
zehn menschen versammeln die
demonstranten brechen diese regel
bewusst in dresden heute sondersitzung
des sächsischen landtags die afg will
die zehn personen regel kippen ganz
offensichtlich sind die zehn personen
regel ja verordnung nicht den
infektionsschutz sie dient einzig dazu
die kritiker der fehlgeschlagenen corona
politik mit fadenscheinigen argumenten
mundtot zu machen
keine beschränkung der teilnehmerzahlen
keine gewalt so die argumentation die
afc wiederum instrumentalisieren die
proteste für ihre politische agenda sind
sich alle anderen parteien einig es ist
eine hitzige diskussion
versammlungsrecht ist ein hohes
demokratisches gut aber wir werden nicht
zulassen dass radikale gruppierungen mit
demokratischen mitteln die demokratie
untergraben
am ende wird der antrag der afg
abgelehnt die demonstrationen in sachsen
und anderswo sind ein katalysator für
eine grundsätzliche demokratie
ablehnende haltungen in einem teil der
gesellschaft corona nur der anlass das
bricht sich jetzt im bahn insofern ist
das eigentlich ja sogar was gut dass das
mal sichtbar wird dass es ein paar
gesellschaftliche bruchlinien gibt einen
kleinen sprechen eher von einer
minderheit die sich aber die aber nicht
integriert ist in dieser demokratische
gesellschaft und die das auch gar nicht
möchte und dass das ein problem mit dem
wir uns einfach auseinander setzen
müssen ein problem das auch im
sächsischen bautzen bleiben wird auch
wenn die korona pandemie irgendwann
geschichte ist
für bundespräsident steinmeier beginnt
das neue jahr erfreulich die zweite
amtszeit für die er sich beworben hat
durfte ihm nun sicher sein damit beginnt
die nachrichten spd fdp und grüne haben
sich bereits für eine wiederwahl von
frank walter steinmeier als
bundespräsident ausgesprochen heute
gaben auch cdu und csu bekannt dass sie
eine zweite amtszeit unterstützen werden
die parteichefs laschet und söder houben
steinmeiers einsatz für demokratie und
zusammenhalt auch in der korona krise
hervor die bundespräsidentenwahl ist für
den 13 februar vorgesehen
vor gut zweieinhalb jahren wurde der
kasseler regierungspräsident walter
lübcke auf seiner terrasse erschossen
nun steht der mutmaßliche verkäufer der
tatwaffe wegen fahrlässiger tötung vor
gericht der 66 jährige angeklagte soll
dem täter die waffe samt munition
bereits 2016 verkauft haben wie der
käufer noch verkäufer sollen eine
waffenerlaubnis gehabt haben der
angeklagte weist die vorwürfe zurück der
täter ein rechtsextremist ist vor einem
jahr zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt
worden
außenministerin berbalk ist in die
us-hauptstadt washington gereist und hat
ihren amerikanischen amtskollegen
blinken getroffen thema war vor allem
die ukraine krise berbalk erklärte eine
erneute verletzung der ukrainischen
souveränität hätte schwere konsequenzen
für russland sollte die situation in der
ukraine weiter eskalieren so blinken sei
schwer vorstellbar dass russisches gas
durch die pipeline nord stream zwei
fließen werde
der eu außenbeauftragte borel fordert
eine größere rolle der europäer bei den
bemühungen zur entschärfung des ukraine
konflikts bei einem besuch in der
ukraine sagte borel jede diskussion zur
europäischen sicherheit müsse die
europäische union und die ukraine mit
einbeziehen die regierung in kiew
sicherte er die volle unterstützung der
eu zu
noch während sich europa auf den
russisch-ukrainischen konflikt
konzentriert gerät eine andere ehemalige
sowjet republik in den blick wladimir
putin ebenfalls zu seinen
einflusssphären rechnet kasachstan eine
diktatur ähnlich wie in weißrussland mit
entsprechenden begleiterscheinungen ein
korrupter familien-clan dessen oberhaupt
seit jahrzehnten die fäden der macht in
den händen hält das zentralasiatische
land ist reich an öl und gas was der
breiten bevölkerung aber nicht zugute
kommt und jetzt brennt es plötzlich in
kasachstan und es riecht geradezu nach
revolution ausgelöst wurden die heftigen
proteste durch massive preiserhöhungen
an den tankstellen die lage im land ist
unübersichtlich axel sturm fasst
zusammen was es bisher an informationen
gibt
die erde bebt in kasachstan vor allem in
albi im süden des landes sturm auf das
verwaltungsgebäude
straßenschlachten blendgranaten training
gas plünderungen eine unklare lage und
der präsident den sie hier nie mit
aufbruch mit reformen verbannten der
sagt es
gibt massive angriffe auf polizisten in
unserer geliebten stadt einige von ihnen
wurden getötet oder verwundet gruppen
von banditen schlagen staatsbeamte
zusammen wären sie nackt durch die
straßen es brauchen frauen brauchen
geschäfte aus all das kann nicht
toleriert werden
toleranz die fehlt vor allem den
demonstranten gegenüber der korruption
im land dem sozialen gefälle den wenig
absurd reichen und in armen menschen das
moderne kasachstan ist ein land dem er
vorsteht kassim somat tkf und dass er
bis heute aus dem hintergrund regiert
nur schultern nasa bei 30 jahre lang war
er präsident dann übergab er das amt
gegen ihn und sein gefolge richtet sich
auch jetzt der zorn die nasa barriere
seine familie sein gefolge und diese
leute die 30 jahre lang die früchte
genossen sich am staatshaushalt
bereichert und geld umverteilt haben sie
schufen diese verteilungs wirtschaft
zugunsten der elite und deshalb sind die
normalen leute die verlierer obwohl sie
offiziell unabhängig wurden
die normalen leute das sind die die
nicht hunderte von millionen schwer sind
wie er es sein soll die normalen leute
die keine teuren immobilien im westen
haben wie er sie haben soll nasarbajew
hat kasachstan aus der sowjetunion
geführt ist dabei reich geworden sein
volk hatte wenig davon
die müdigkeit ist enorm 30 jahren
kabarett wir reden nicht einmal über
gestern wir reden über
sie sind wütend wütend weil es keine
weiterentwicklung gibt weil der
präsident der nach dem rekordzeit
präsidenten kam für sie nichts mehr ist
als mehr vom gleichen weil ihr öl und
gas reiches land weiter wenige noch
reicher macht und weiter äußerst
autoritär regiert wird deshalb
kasachstan zur zeit der frust ist groß
einige haben darum symbolisch dem alten
herrscher die schlinge um den hals
gelegt
und jetzt nochmal eins mit dem blick auf
die deutsche wirtschaft mit einer
weiteren bilanz zum vergangenen jahr die
zahl der auto neuzulassungen in
deutschland ist da erneut deutlich
zurückgegangen das zeigen die zahlen des
kraftfahrtbundesamtes sina mainitz was
man die gründe dafür ja das sind
beispielsweise die lieferprobleme wenn
es um elektronikbauteile geht oder der
nach wie vor anhaltende chip mangel 2021
wurden deshalb in deutschland so wenig
autos verkauft wie seit der
wiedervereinigung nicht mehr vergangenes
jahr kamen rund 2,6 millionen neuwagen
auf die straßen das waren zehn prozent
weniger als im corona bedingt bereits
schwachen jahr 2020 laut ifo-institut
bleibt die stimmung in der autobranche
getrübt autohersteller sind abhängig von
chips die im ausland gefertigt werden
und wenn diese fehlen können auch die
zulieferer nicht produzieren ausgenommen
von der negativen entwicklung waren
alternative antriebe mehr als jedes
zehnte neu zugelassene fahrzeug war
vergangenes jahr ein reines elektroauto
fast 300 56.000 autos waren mit einem
entsprechenden antrieb ausgestattet und
83 prozent mehr als im jahr davor
autohändler geben kaum noch rabatte das
luxus segment boomt und dort gibt es
hohe margen so hat die branche trotz der
bekannten probleme gut verdient das
treibt auch die autoaktien heute ins
plus der dax beendet den dritten
handelstag des neuen jahres auch im plus
bei einem stand von 16.200 72 punkten
und für dieses jahr rechnet die branche
endlich wieder mit aufwind angesichts
der pandemie ein großes fragezeichen
sina mainitz vielen dank
dritter sieg im dritten springen der
japaner ryo kobayashi ist nach dem
erfolg in bischofshofen auf dem besten
weg zum gesamtsieg bei der
vierschanzentournee
hoffnungen auf einen podestplatz in der
tournee-wertung dürfen sich noch karl
geiger und markus eisenbichler machen
gewonnen hat erneut der japanische ist
seriensieger rio kobayashi markus
eisenbichler dagegen bleibt nur applaus
für die konkurrenz nach verpatztem
ersten sprung so ruht die hoffnung des
deutschen teams auf einen podestplatz
allein auf karl geiger der sechste der
gesamtwertung und führte nach dem ersten
sprung mit einem schönen flug auf
sich meter verbessern aber kann er sich
damit nicht war für mich heute das ziel
wieder spur zu finden einfluss ausbauen
rhythmus aufbauen und zwei gute sprünge
zu machen deshalb das war heute echt gut
und ich bin zufrieden gewohnt nerven
stark und technisch brillant einmal mehr
der tournee sieger des vorjahres
kobayashi mit
137,5 metern verdrängt der japaner den
nach dem ersten sprung führenden
norweger lind weg noch auf rang zwei in
der gesamtwertung baute seine führung
von entwickler aus auf 4 der tages 8d
reisenbichler karl geiger knapp dahinter
auf 5
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
67 32
41 und die superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotte punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
die arktis da denken die meisten an
nordpol eisbären und eisberge
schmelzende eisberge wohl gemerkt wie
massiv sich der klimawandel gerade in
der arktis bemerkbar macht ist
allgemeinwissen
weniger im bewusstsein ist vielleicht
dass die arktis eine der geopolitisch
heißesten weltregionen ist spielort
eines globalen machtpokers von dem nicht
nur die unmittelbaren anrainer staaten
betroffen sind und durch die eisschmelze
hat sich die strategische bedeutung der
arktis noch einmal gewaltig erhöht
darüber und was das für das leben das
bedeutet berichtet unser korrespondent
johannes hano in einer zweiteiligen doku
erste teil folgt jetzt gleich im
anschluss ans heute-journal und hier
vorab schon mal ein auszug
wir sind unterwegs durch die arktis kaum
jemand hat sie jesu gesehen
wir wollen verstehen wie sich diese welt
ändert und was das für uns alle bedeutet
vor uns liegt eine abenteuerliche reise
viele stunden über unbewohntes gebiet an
die einsamsten orte dieser welt
[Musik]
an der grönländischen ostküste haben wir
uns zu einem experiment verabredet wir
sind unterwegs mit zwei booten im score
es bis und dem größten fjord system der
welt wollen versuchen mit der familie
basel reisen in das sommercamp der
walfänger vorzudringen das liegt gut 250
kilometer tief im inneren des hauses
noch nie hat es jemand geschafft jetzt
ende oktober so tief in den fjord
vorzudringen auf halber strecke fast
fünf stunden sind wir schon unterwegs
eine geschützte bucht an einer kleinen
insel hier lagert in der bucht band
zieht und vorräte
wenn wir im fjord nicht weiterkommen
weil alles zugefroren ist dann kommen
wir zurück und schlagen unser camp
ich war noch nie im oktober
noch nie
es sollte mehr eis geben es ist viel zu
warm
eine aussage die uns etwas irritiert
denn mittlerweile ist das thermometer
auf unter minus zehn grad gefallen wir
kommen vorbei an einer gletscherzunge
die aus dem eispanzer weit hinein in den
vortrag jahrtausende altes eis dass wir
bislang nur von oben gesehen haben seine
schichten erinnern an baumringe
baumringe der erdgeschichte
auf einem der blau schimmernden
eisblöcke blut und argument eisbären
müssten in der nähe seien wir sollten
jetzt besser aufpassen und er warnt dass
anderen mut
und dann sehen wir sie auch schon sechs
bären sind es
einer von ihnen hat blut an kopf und
hals
wahrscheinlich haben wir sie gerade beim
fressen gestört
an land ein kadaver die reste eines nahm
als jäger hätten ihn geschossen aber die
bären hätten sich wohl durchgesetzt
malaga waljagd werde immer schwieriger
menschen und bären hätten durch den
klimawandel in den letzten beiden jahren
konkurrenz bekommen
killer wales und ein großes problem für
die jäger denn sie fressen robben nach
wale und andere phase
und die kommen dann nicht mehr zu uns in
den vier und wenn es zu viele killerwale
gibt
dieses jahr haben die jäger zum ersten
mal einen killerwal erlegt
wir müssen uns beeilen denn wenn es
dunkel wird wird es sehr gefährlich bei
all den eisbergen die durch den vor ort
und eine seitenansicht
an den hängen immer wieder wesen wie aus
einer anderen zeit moschusochsen in
ihren langen dicken fellen der kälte auf
dem arktischen winter trotz
stundenlang geht es weiter durch raues
wasser bei temperaturen von jetzt etwa
minus 15 grad
als vor und seine geschlossene eisdecke
auftaucht unser kleines boot ja zum
eisbrecher und wir fragen uns ob wir es
überhaupt noch schaffen werden das camp
am ende dieses riesigen klotz zu
erreichen
und die reise dann weiter gegangen ist
können sie jetzt direkt im anschluss
sehen gleich nach dem wetter und um 0.10
meldet sich dann gundula gause mit
unserem heute schnell update wir melden
uns morgen wieder bis dahin futtert sie
[Musik]
guten abend umzingelt von gleich drei
teams nämlich mit dem tiefsee mimen und
barbara wird sich morgen das kleine
zwischenhoch alex zu uns durchkämpfen
das bringt uns dann wenigstens mal für
einen tag sonnenschein es vertreibt die
schneewolken nach osten allerdings kommt
dann schon bald das nächste tief barbara
heran bringt regen und vor allen dingen
erst einmal schnee mit aber schnee und
regen beschäftigen uns auch in der nacht
das sind doch etliche schauer die da im
wesentlichen noch von norden nach süden
über uns hinweg ziehen und so kann es
gefährlich glatt werden auf den straßen
durch schnee schneeregen schnee matsch
und auch dort wo es aufklart wie zum
beispiel hier in schleswig holstein denn
die temperaturen sinken auf plus 2 bis
minus fünf grad dabei wird es am
alpenrand genauso kalt wie in
nordfriesland die nächsten touren morgen
liegen bei minus 1 grad am alpenrand
oder auch in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und maximal sechs grad im
rhein main gebiet oder auch in
ostfriesland morgen vormittag kann es
noch ein bisschen schneien am alpenrand
und auch richtung thüringer wald und
erzgebirge dann aber setzt sich auch
dort freundliches wetter durch und
besonders strahlend scheint die sonne
von der ostseeküste bis zum harz am
freitag kommt das angesprochene nächste
tief bringt er es schnee und dann regen
und glättegefahr und das wiederholt sich
samstag und sonntag genauso guten abend